just in time for the long weekend if
you've got kids like I do you definitely
need something to do over Thanksgiving
weekend other than just stare at each
other and eat food what you do is you go
see the the sequel to wreck-it Ralph
Ralph breaks the Internet in theaters
near you starting on Wednesday we had
Jane Lynch last week to promote it along
with john c reilly is coming in a couple
weeks we love Sarah Silverman and then
the man am i right good to see you Jack
McBrayer yeah you bet you know now you
just reminded me in the commercial break
we have done comedy together every no
yes sir we have a storied past did you
know this Brockman that I did comedy
with Jack McBrayer now when was that
okay so now this is had to be about ten
years ago right Oh at least I would say
2005 maybe it's okay so a long time ago
sir and here in Los Angeles and it was
improv was it not yes it was
improvisational comedy you were an
incredible asset I've ever been called
an incredible asset before in the
four-year history of this program I mean
let me go back and think before so there
I was on the stage it was the famed
Armando show here in Los Angeles
California
hadith correct where again it was just
to go up there and act out something
from my past my own path true you would
share a true story from your past and
then the group of improvisers would
create scenes based on your stories
right and then hopefully respectfully
remember you it was Tim Meadows I think
yes there too absolutely no it's all
coming back to me there you go man what
there's nothing more from what I have
done in my career if you will or life
nothing is more frightening than
stand-up comedy or improv comedy like
that I do understand the challenge it
could create but hey you were natural
and like take a bit of a deep dive
they'll see it's not nearly as scary
okay so how did you get involved in it
my background I started in Chicago right
after college the second city improv
Olympic are the big comedy theaters
there
and it was one of those things where
once I saw it yet I was like this is
what I want to do right and so I got
inspired started taking the classes got
hired got the tour and then you got to
go around the country gotta go now I've
spent time in Chicago yeah I must say
Jack you don't sound like somebody from
Chicago Southside okay
the south side of the United States and
where are you from originally from
Georgia
you're from Jewish so how'd you get to
Chicago well I went to college in
Indiana just to try something new okay
and then after college I knew I wanted
to try a big-city right but I didn't
necessarily want to go back to Atlanta
right so then I started exploring and it
was between like st. Louis or Louisville
Chicago then you show Chicago or which
is you know so that you did did you do
second city there did that's where I met
Tina Fey I mean there's quite a list of
alumni yeah okay so drop names let's do
it well it was who was there at Second
City with you Adam McKay was there when
I first started Tina Fey Rachel Dratch
Scott Adsit who exactly um Jon Glaser so
many of the writers for Conan O'Brien
Jon Glaser I did stand-up with in
Michigan you did yeah he's a Michigan
guy I didn't know that I didn't know
about that I did stand-up with Jon
Glaser I did and lived to tell about
live to tell you to your face Jack
McBrayer right here on the show I don't
know if I believe it was that one so
when Tina's they put 30 rock together is
that the connection yes sir I had known
her and her husband her husband was my
director at second city so I had known
him since the mid 90s okay and when it
came time for her to develop 30 rock I
think she definitely had me in mind I
still had to audition but she had me in
mind for the page room obviously I say
how much fun was that
did you it changed my life it changed my
life I wouldn't I probably would not be
in wreck-it Ralph or Ralphie eggs the
Internet if it weren't for 30 rock so I
owe Tina Fey along what's your what's
your favorite episode of 30 rock oh geez
we only ask the tough questions here
jack ah boy this is too hot for TV
good thing we're on the radio too there
was one episode where I got to perform
with my comedy hero Tim Conway
and I got to spend the entire episode
with them and then just like pick his
brain listen to his stories and that was
that was the icing on the cake from the
old Carol Burnett Show I love them like
nobody that's your gate that's your
entry or comedy and Conway done not yes
sir
dawn no I could see a lot of the Don
Knotts in that jack yeah the chin line I
could I could see that should this drawn
jaw line exactly so who's the one
because Tim Conway the the the best
parts of the Carol Burnett Show was when
they would start laughing absolutely
okay we made a bit break up you know so
who's the one that that breaks you up
and in the history of you doing that
you've done what made you laugh the
easiest maybe accidentally Tracy Morgan
bless its heart but you'll be doing a
scene with them and you will get the
giggles because sometimes it sometimes
just take a little longer right
but uh yeah other than that the shows
like that we're such an inspiration for
what I wanted to get into ensembles
working together playing well with each
other right right
a Jack McBrayer here on the Rich Eisen
show so you have done work with Blake
Griffin aha current Detroit piston but
you did it back in the Clipper days
right he's my best friend
okay now what did you did car
commercials there was a Kia commercial
that we did in 2014 and I can't say
enough good things about him that dude
is funny that dude is funny he missed
his collar he does have the chops I
think he did the roast battle with uh
with Jeffrey Ross correct sir like he
got actually in the roast battle ring
yeah with the roastmaster general once
you better have your big-boy pants on
for that one and I do not sir hold on a
second
to me one of the things that I
definitely knew that I could not do in
the stand-up comedy world there were two
things one is I just I knew I wasn't cut
out for the the grind right I was not
cut out for the here's your 20 bucks in
the cheeseburger for doing your set
tonight I was not cut out for that
understood but the other things I was
not cut out for is to put myself in
uncomfortable situations just for the
comedy and you know we were watching
before the show today of the many things
that you have
with with triumph yes sir the insult
comic dog for Conan O'Brien to go up to
the line at the Wiener circle in Chicago
Illinois and do what you did
was quite something else I mean yeah
come on now jack so you've got you've
got big boy pants on that front right
there my therapist has earned a lot of
money from this how did you approach
that whole thing we're just gonna go up
there or did you I mean take his behind
the scenes of that one okay well it was
proposed by the producers at Conan and
Robert Smigel I had of course seen his
work with Conan before and so I said yes
and trusted he trusted the the process
and I do have to say however long that
clip is like six minutes eight minutes
actually that was there for nine hours
come on now
yeah and you were getting the business
from the staff at the Wiener circle for
nine straight hours at least the food
was good right you didn't even you'd
even taste the dude even sample there's
like hot dogs I know I lived in Chicago
all those years I don't like hot dogs
with all due respect to the hug it's
okay I don't know if you're sorry you
not a ketchup guy or no cuz in Chicago
that's that that would be the ultimate
now that is true you're not supposed to
put ketchup on a hot dog which I do not
understand and put whatever you like
exactly means not great for you neither
haggis Isis I went to the Wiener circle
once before I don't recall it it was
2:00 in the morning and I definitely had
a few in me from Rush Street Truong yes
there's a definitely a demographic joint
people and you are not one a part of
that demographic not that night so
congrats on Ralph breaks the internet
man this is gonna be great I mean I'm
sure you've worked with Sarah Silverman
before right love her Ed O'Neill yeah so
who are you in the studio with actually
just working with the one time I was
with john c reilly the other times I was
with Jane Lynch because it's super
mission my seams with I think I figured
out between the first movie and the
second movie I'm not positive I have any
scenes with Sarah Silverman at all I
think that was in her country she was in
the Roger
he's rude do not trust her
yeah so she's in that too this is gonna
be great it's it it's in theaters near
you
starting tomorrow yes so I look forward
to it Jack thanks for coming on the show
man really appreciate you having you on
I'm a big fan my wife's a big fan too
good luck with everything that you're
doing and come back anytime we got it
you got a Jack McBrayer here on the rich
Ozzy show I noticed you're not even on
you're not on Twitter you're not on
anything like that say you know you're -
you're like you miss you're you're like
you know calling people sir and being so
kind yeah you don't want to get ruined
by Twitter thank you keep namaste
namaste is right I don't even know if
that would be right there's no namaste
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience